we've got some news um out of scotland  and that is that  in aberdeen lockdown restrictions are to  be reimposed and that is because  um 54 new cases have emerged in a  coronavirus cluster  it was announced by the first minister a  few moments ago let's have a listen  confirm that it was agreed at score this  morning albeit as i'm sure you  understand  extremely reluctantly to reimpose some  restrictions  on the aberdeen city area and i want to  set out what those restrictions are  it will let me remind you because i know  particularly for people living in  aberdeen there will be lots of questions  that we will make  more detail available over the course of  the day to give as much clarity  to people as possible